today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
i actually wasn't going to talk about
this today because my priority as many
of you know is bringing the left
together to defeat donald trump
and i thought over the weekend when i
saw this story that talking about it
might be divisive but now that i'm
seeing some of the reactions i'm
realizing that i have to talk about it
to try to stop the divisiveness so let's
get right into it
in my mind noam chomsky has never made
more sense
than he has made in the last six months
in terms of
the urgency and the importance of voting
and of removing donald trump and he's
spoken really astutely and poignantly
to the ante biden left to the never
biden left to people who in 2016 thought
there was no practical difference
between donald trump and hillary clinton
and he recently said and i'm
paraphrasing here
that while you might be frustrated that
you would have to lobby biden to be
more left that under trump your city
might just be underwater and it's hard
to be an activist
for anything you care about if your city
is under water and this was metaphorical
in nature but it lines up 110
with what i've been saying to everybody
for years now so noam chomsky was
interviewed on a podcast by brianna joy
gray
who was previously on the bernie
campaign and a guy named virgil texas
who i'm not familiar with but i
understand he's on
uh the chapo podcast which i've i've
never seen actually but i believe is is
sort of prominent in some parts of the
left
and they argued with him about
approaches to the election and after
the interview all sorts of divisive
leftist takes came
out saying chomsky lost this debate
and people should not vote for joe biden
and it's really been depressing to see
so let's look at the first clip and talk
about it what are the long-term
consequences
of everybody on the broad left democrats
liberals
everyone saying that under any
circumstances
we will vote for a democratic candidate
as long as they are
incrementally better than the republican
candidate does that way of thinking
contribute to the rightward shift
of the democratic party over years and
what mechanism will ever stop that shift
if we're not
willing to ever under any circumstances
leverage our votes
what you're saying if you think it
through is
we should help trump win because maybe
in the long run that'll affect the
democratic party
that's a terrible choice so this is
merely
dressed up accelerationism it's taking
a lame dry cookie and putting good
frosting on it so to speak it's the idea
that by punishing the democratic party
and the country mind you
since you're conceding it would be
incrementally better to have biden
but you're choosing something else
you're saying punish the country
punish people the planet so that maybe
at some future point
things get so bad that then it really
moves to the left in the united states
it hasn't worked in history
and noam chomsky lays it out here
helping trump
win as you're proposing would mean
four more years of destruction of the
environment
getting possibly the tipping points that
which would be irreversible
certainly making any effort to deal with
it very difficult
it would mean stacking the judiciary
with young ultra-right lawyers
top to bottom so that nothing would be
possibly done for a generation
and i can go on and on i don't think
that's a wise choice
just on the hope that maybe sometime in
the long term
the democratic party will pay attention
to the fact that you're
part of the 50 of non-voters what noam
chomsky is talking about
are the irreversible damages
irreversible climate damage
not irreversible but at least
irreversible for decades
rightward shifts in the judiciary by
giving trump
more judges in a second term there are
millions and millions of americans who
can't afford that
and you know i've said before this isn't
about me
i could easily say sure put trump in
another four years it'll be wacky it'll
be entertaining my show will do better
and then we'll finally go
super left in 2024 because the truth is
i'm fine either way i'll get more clicks
if trump is president
i live in massachusetts where i'm
protected
from some but not all of this stuff not
the climate stuff for sure
that would be outrageously self-centered
for me to do and noam chomsky points
that out the damage to the population
from climate and judges alone
makes this idea immoral let's look at a
little more of this here
here's chomp chomsky really uh
distilling this very clearly
now we have a simple question do you
want your grandchildren to survive
i think the people you're talking to say
yes i want my grandchildren
so many people's grandchildren are
already not surviving
that's that's the issue you want to
ensure that they'll live under water
or have a chance to survive so many
people aren't thinking about living
underwater because they're incarcerated
or they're
unhomed then as an activist your goal is
to make
get them to think about it because that
is what is at stake
again crystal clear and pitch perfect is
noam chomsky
truly this is the most sense chomsky has
made in a long time
here's one other clip with the other
host virgil texas
and chomsky again explaining the urgency
of the situation and the absurdity that
another four years of trump
might bring some socialist takeover in
the next decades
if these institutions if these
capitalist institutions
result in recurring ecological crises
and existential ones as they do
then isn't the real fight against those
institutions instead of a reform that
maybe gets us over the hump in 30 years
if it were possible to lobby those in
power through
activism some kind of brokering uh those
who are
beholden to the profit motive even if it
destroys the environment
we have maybe a decade or two to deal
with the environmental crisis
is there the remotest chance that within
a decade or two
will overthrow capitalism it's not even
a dream
okay so the quest with a point that
you're raising
is basically irrelevant of course
let's work to try to overthrow
capitalism
it's not going to happen like that
there's a lot of work involved
meanwhile we have an imminent
question are we going to preserve the
possibility
for organized human society to survive
are we going to preserve the possibility
for us
to work to overthrow capitalist
institutions
or are we going to say it's hopeless
let's quit i prefer the first
you're calling for the second so chomsky
is just spot on and unfortunately people
that are proclaiming that chomsky was
defeated here
it's created a second round of
cheerleading
of people feeling better about not
voting biden and it's really tragic and
as chomsky says
let's be activists for stuff once biden
wins
but if biden doesn't win our activism
goes nowhere there's no chance of
anything if trump wins and that's the
key point that chomsky is making here
let's be united around it
this is not a debate about blue no
matter who i don't even know who's
seriously saying
that there's a any sort of validity to
blue no matter who
it's trump and biden
biden happens to be the democratic
candidate trump happens to be the
republican candidate
we've evaluated two options and picked
the better one
making this a debate about the concept
of voting for the democrat whoever they
are is ridiculous we're 21 days out
and it's biden versus trump it's not
blue no matter who or blue if this or
blue is that
really well done by noam chomsky let's
come together around it
yesterday was day two of amy coney
barrett's confirmation hearings to the
supreme court
barrett is donald trump's nominee to
replace the late great ruth bader
ginsburg
barrett couldn't possibly come from a
more different philosophy
than ginsburg barrett is a religious
christian
a member of a cult named the people of
praise who said antonin scalia was the
most in line with her
judicial philosophy day two of the
confirmation hearings
truly a clinic in obfuscation and
deception and what's
stunning about yesterday's second day of
hearings is that i don't think amy coney
barrett actually
said anything directly about her
philosophy her answers were either
saying nothing and explaining why she'll
be saying nothing
or telegraphing her positions in a coy
and deceptive way
while leaving herself complete latitude
to do anything
in the future and all sorts of senators
taking a shot at it just
a pathetic lack of openness sometimes it
was almost comical
and i say almost comical because then
you remember wait
she might be influencing the top level
judiciary of the country for decades
when you're about to laugh you remember
that and you stop laughing
so let's look at some examples there is
speculation that donald trump will
dispute the election
if he does it could reach the supreme
court so chris coons democratic senator
asked barrett whether she'd recuse
herself from any cases related to this
election since it would be an obvious
conflict
having to adjudicate an election in
which the guy who nominated you
is a candidate but she won't she won't
recuse herself
but i think the gravimen the court the
the core issue
in recusal is that any judge or justice
should recuse themselves from a case in
which their impartiality
might reasonably be questioned
given what president trump said given
the rushed
context of this confirmation will you
commit to recusing yourself
from any case arising from a dispute in
the presidential election
results three weeks from now senator
coons thank you for giving me the
opportunity to clarify this because i
want to be very clear for the record and
to all members of this committee
that no matter what anyone else may
think or
expect i have not committed
to anyone or so much as signaled i've
never even written i've been in a couple
of opinions in the seventh circuit that
have been around the edges of election
law
but i haven't even written anything that
i would think anybody could reasonably
say oh this is how she might resolve an
election dispute
so she does not commit to that and why
would she i mean there's been no
consequences to anything
any of donald trump's cronies have done
why would she recuse herself no way
no surprise at all then it goes to cory
booker democratic senator from new
jersey
who asks about the importance of
presidents committing to a
peaceful transfer of power something
that presidents
should commit themselves to generally
and she won't answer that
cory booker presses her and she still
won't do it
he asked at this time here's another one
do you believe that every president
should make a commitment
unequivocally and resolutely to the
peaceful
transfer of power
well senator that seems to me
to be pulling me in a little bit into
this question of whether
the president has said that he would not
peacefully leave
office and so to the extent that this is
a political controversy right now
as a judge i want to stay out of it and
i don't want to express a view
on so judge i i appreciate you what
you've said about respecting our
founding fathers about the originalism
it's remarkable that we're at a place
right now that this is becoming a
question and a topic but i'm asking
you in light of our founding fathers
and loud of our traditions in light that
everyone who serves in that office has
sworn an oath
where they quote swear to preserve and
protect and defend the constitution of
the united states
i'm just asking you should a president
commit themselves
like our founding fathers i think have a
clear intention
like the grace that george washington
showed
to the peaceful transfer of power is
that something that presidents
should be able to do well one of the
beauties
of america from the beginning of the
republic is that we have
had peaceful transfers of power and that
disappointed voters have accepted the
new leaders that come into office
and that's not true in every country and
i think it is part of the genius of our
constitution
did you see what she did there when
asked about
whether presidents should commit to
peaceful transfers of power
she says the great thing about the us is
we've always had peaceful transfers of
power which of course ignores
that we've never had a president like
trump who won't actually commit to one
but she leaves that out conveniently
really interesting moment when it was
senator kamala harris's turn kamala asks
whether barrett is aware
that donald trump has made comments
about striking down the affordable care
act
and is pursuing lawsuits to strike down
the affordable care act and barrett says
she hasn't heard of them but
harris was prepared and harris says
well while you were talking to people
getting ready for these hearings
certainly the topic must have come up
right and this puts barrett
into a pretzel where she has to admit
well
yeah i was told it might come up but not
in the context of trump
pledging to eliminate and suing to
eliminate the aca
doesn't pass the sniff test let's take a
look eric
i asked you earlier today but did not
receive an answer
prior to your nomination were you
aware of president trump's statements
committing to nominate judges who will
strike down the affordable care act and
i'd appreciate a yes or no answer please
well senator harris i want to be very
very careful i'm under oath
i as i'm sitting here i don't recall
seeing those statements but if
let's see i don't recall seeing or
hearing those statements
but i don't really know what context
they were in so i guess i can't really
definitively give you a yes or no answer
what i would like to say is i don't
recall
hearing about or seeing such statements
well i imagine you were surrounded by a
team of folks that helped prepare you
for this nomination
hearing i haven't heard that yesterday
but let me finish if you don't mind i'm
so sorry did they
inform you of the president's statements
and that this might be a question
that was presented to you during the
course of this hearing
um when i had my calls with senators
it came up many of many of the
democratic senators wanted to know about
the affordable care act and to
satisfy themselves that i had not made
any pre-commitments to the president
about it and so you then became aware of
the president's statement is that
correct
um let's see senator harris
in the context of these conversations i
honestly can't remember whether senators
framed the questions in the context of
president trump's comments
perhaps so i think from my perspective
the most important thing is to say that
i have never made a commitment i've
never been asked to make a commitment
and i hope that the committee would
trust in my integrity so
understand that barrett says well
the affordable care act did come up with
multiple senators
but not in the context of what trump
said she wants us to believe
she had multiple conversations about the
affordable care act
without it ever being mentioned that
trump has been on a four-year rampage
including lawsuits to get rid of the
affordable care act
completely not believable now as a brief
interlude
check out this hard-hitting question
from republican senator ben sasse
tell us about the scalia ginsburg
friendship and the uh the
impact that it made on you really tough
stuff right so that was that was a
republican interlude
now back to real questions in this next
one senator dianne feinstein lanes
lays out a question which is you say you
were like scalia
scalia didn't think gay people should
get married could get married legally
what do you think now
you said in your acceptance speech for
this nomination that
justice scalia's philosophy is your
philosophy
do you agree with this particular point
of justice scalia's view that the u.s
constitution does not afford gay people
the fundamental right to marry
senator feinstein as i said to senator
graham at the outset
if i were confirmed you would be getting
justice barrett not justice scalia
so i don't think that anybody should
assume that just because justice scalia
decided decision a certain way
that i would too but i'm not going to
express a view on whether i agree or
disagree with justice scalia for the
same reasons that i've been giving
you know justice ginsburg with her
characteristic pithiness
used this way this to describe um how a
nominee should comport herself
at a hearing so that's a game barrett
plays she is smart where she will
cite ruth bader ginsburg in some
innocuous
way to avoid answering a real question
and
feinstein tries again on roe v wade
doesn't get any further with it
so on something that is really
a major cause with major effect
on over half of the population of this
country who are women
after all it's it's distressing not to
get a straight answer
so let me try again do you agree with
justice scalia's view
that roe was wrongly decided
senator i completely understand why you
are
asking the question but again
i can't pre-commit or say yes i'm going
in with some agenda because i'm not
i don't have any agenda i have no agenda
to try to overrule casey
i have an agenda to stick to the rule of
law and decide cases as they come
they often use this framing to avoid
answering i'll decide cases as they
as they come up uh speculating about
past decisions you know
so you never get any actual answer out
of them and then lastly from yesterday
there's more but these are some
highlights
here's amy klobuchar asking very simply
do you agree it's illegal to intimidate
voters at the polls
and barrett says it's a hypothetical
it's not it's simply a question about
the law
judge barrett under federal law is it
illegal to intimidate voters at the
polls
senator klobuchar i can't characterize
the facts in a hypothetical situation
and i can't apply the law to a
hypothetical set
of facts i can only decide cases as they
come to me litigated by parties on a
full record
after fully engaging precedent talking
to colleagues writing an opinion
and so i can't answer questions like
that well i'll make i'll make it easier
18 usc 594 outlaws
anyone who intimidates threatens coerces
or attempts to intimidate threaten or
coerce
any other person for the purpose of
interfering with the right of such other
person to vote
this is a law that has been on the books
for decades so no
answer there either so what did we learn
yesterday we learned quite simply
that amy coney barrett is really
slippery
and will say nothing and republicans
will come out of these hearings say
they were very pleased with amy coney
barrett's performance
let's go and vote her in in all
likelihood
it's what will happen let me know what
you thought about yesterday's hearings
i'm on twitter
at d pacman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so nancy pelosi democratic speaker of
the house went on cnn she was
interviewed by wolf blitzer
it didn't go very well and she's uh
correctly understandably taking some
heat
for how this all went down so let's look
at it i
have some thoughts let's get right right
into the first clip
first off wolf blitzer asks why won't
you accept the republican proposal for
coronavirus relief
and nancy pelosi says it's a bad deal
for the people as you know there are
americans
who are being evicted from their homes
they can't pay the rent
many americans are waiting in food lines
for the first time
in their lives can you look them in the
eye madam speaker and explain
why you don't want to accept the
president's latest stimulus offer
well because thank you very much wolf
and i i hope you'll ask the same
question
of the republicans about why they don't
really want to meet the needs of the
american people
but let me say to those people because
all of my colleagues
we represent these people i have for
over 30 years
represented my constituents i know what
their needs are
i listen to them and their needs are not
addressed
in the president's proposal so when you
say
to me why don't you accept theirs why
don't they accept
ours so this is okay so far but then it
starts to get heated as wolf blitzer
pushes back and nancy pelosi
goes after wolfe and his colleagues
and this is where it started to not not
be so good excuse me for interrupting
let's go back
madam speaker but they really need the
money right now uh and even members of i
have you know that but
but
members of your own caucus madam speaker
uh want to accept this deal 1.8 trillion
dollars congressman roe connor
for example let me just let me just
quote ro connor a man you know well
i assume you admire him he's a democrat
and he just said this he said people in
need can't wait
until february 1.8 trillion dollars
is significant and more than twice the
obama stimulus
make a deal put the ball in mcconnell
court so what do you say to roe connor
what i say to you is i don't know why
you're always an apologist
and many of your colleagues apologize
for the republican position
ro khanna that's nice that isn't what
we're going to do and nobody's waiting
till february
i want this very much now so
now nancy pelosi is starting to get
agitated with wolf blitzer
and he's asking completely fair
questions thus far
the problem here is not wolff blitzer
he's being a journalist and here wolf
blitzer tries again
that's precisely why they're short their
concerns that's why
it's so important right now yesterday i
spoke to andrew yang who says the same
thing it's not everything you want you
know there's a lot there
honest to god you really uh i can't get
over it
because andrew yang he's lovely yo khan
rokhana he's lovely they are not
negotiating
this situation they have no idea of the
particulars
they have no idea of what the language
is here i didn't come over here to have
so you're the apologist for the obama
and excuse me
god forbid madam speaker
so now nancy pelosi starts to get
flustered
and i think that basically everybody's
being sort of unfair in their reactions
here it is absolutely true that wolf
blitzer is doing nothing wrong he's
asking questions he's asking reasonable
questions
questions we all deserve answers to
which essentially are
if you want coronavirus relief and trump
is willing to do something on it why
wouldn't you just take it and nancy
pelosi has to explain that she has to
that that's some
that's fair that's completely reasonable
yes nancy pelosi is wrong to go after
wolf
and cnn because he's just asking
questions and reasonable ones and
attacking
the the journalist is a very bad look
but in addition to that without
defending nancy pelosi
she's dealing with a lunatic in donald
trump in trying to get this coronavirus
stimulus done and that frustration is
clearly
coming through here now her most astute
statement
uh there is that neither yang nor
rokhana
are negotiating this with trump and it
has to be
insane to be negotiating this with trump
so i
sympathize with her for that but ex
letting the uh frustration boil over on
wolf blitzer as if he's asking bad
questions
is a terrible look and wolf comes back
in with more questions
let me ask you this when was the last
time let me
when was the last time you spoke with
the president about this
i don't speak the presidency
why not call him and say mr president
let's work out a deal it's not going to
be everything you want
not going to be everything i want but
there are so many americans right now
who are in desperate need let's make a
deal
what makes me amused if it weren't so
sad
is how you all think that you know more
about the suffering of the american
people
than those of us who are elected by them
to represent them
at that table it is unfortunate that we
do not have shared values
with this white house and that they have
in their bill
why don't you talk about in their bill a
tax break for the wealthiest families in
the country
while they cut out the earned income tax
credit for the poorest families in our
country
and the poorest children in our country
so again
nancy pelosi saying it's wolf who has no
idea
it's not his job to have an idea here
uh wolf is there as a journalist to ask
questions like
if trump's okay with 1.8 trillion why
won't you take it and get money to
people
that's fair and there are reasonable
people on the left
asking that exact same question and
pelosi could tackle that without
attacking wolf blitzer
it's a mistake she's making a mistake i
get the frustration
and the frustration grows in this next
clip
it will be wretched here's what you
wrote in a letter to house democrats
madam speaker and i ask these questions
only as you know
so many millions of americans are
suffering from you right two
people who know nothing about the
agreement or
there is no agreement but what the
suggestions are as if there's some
authority
on the subject please give equal weight
to 12
to all of the chairman on the committee
who have written
this but so many of your fellow
democrats in the house they want
a deal right now the problem solvers
they all want a deal right now and
here's what they're complaining about
because
you wrote a letter to house democrats
and you said this let me read a line
from the letter
uh you wrote the president only wants
his name on a check to go out before
election day
and for the market to go up is that what
this is all about
not allow the president to take credit
if there's a deal that will help
millions of americans
right now he's not that important but
let me say this
with all due respect with all due
respect and you know we've known each
other a long time
you really don't know what you're
talking about if the plural of anecdote
is not data
yes there's some people who said this or
that overwhelmingly
my caucus wants what is right for the
american people
overwhelmingly our chairman who wrote
the bill read their statements
they all put out their own statements
when they saw what the
white house was proposing so this was
bad
that this is very very bad i understand
why pelosi's fuse is running short
but this is like when the trump people
are sent out to defend trump
and they get frustrated because trump
lies all the time and then they have to
defend trump's lies on media uh in media
interviews
and they end up attacking the
interviewer when the trump defenders do
it it's wrong
and when nancy pelosi does it it's wrong
and it's a bad look
so this did go horribly wrong but not
because pelosi was frustrated
she should have pushed the frustration
onto trump and republicans and she
should have said listen wolf
you're doing your job and you're asking
reasonable questions which the american
people deserve answers to
understand what's going on trump says
he'll sign off on money so why hasn't it
been
been done very reasonable but understand
the impossible position i'm in
where trump tells me no deal via twitter
via
twitter last week trump says no deal
stop negotiating
then he goes to a rally and says get
people money the democrats won't i say
i'm
i'm for money the democrats aren't mitch
mcconnell says
no more deals mitch mcconnell has been
saying for months we're not doing any
more stimulus
understand the bipolar nature of the
situation and then i'm thrown into it so
your questions of me are fair but
recognize the insanity but when she goes
off on wolf it backfires completely
it makes her an unsympathetic character
and now she has to deal with the fallout
from this interview so
wolf blitzer did nothing wrong it's
nancy pelosi who was in the wrong
understanding her frustration with the
completely
manic bipolar insanity of trying to
negotiate this with a donald trump
who says something different every two
hours on twitter at a rally so on and so
forth
that's essentially my my take on the way
this went down
let's talk now briefly about dr anthony
fauci
dr fauci has finally had enough and is
now straight up saying
the trump campaign is harassing me and
hell no i'm not going to quit my job
remember that dr fauci is the top
infectious disease doctor in the u.s
he's been increasingly sidelined and
ignored by the trump campaign
he was pulled out of the public eye
after being in it early in the pandemic
he was blocked from doing tv interviews
by the trump administration
and what looks to be the last straw for
him is that he was taken out of context
and used in a trump campaign ad
in a way that sort of makes it look like
fauci is endorsing trump when it was
actually completely out of context
fauci asked about this while on cnn over
the weekend take a look
i i do have to ask you about this trump
campaign advertisement where you're on
camera saying quote i can't imagine
that anybody could be doing more you
quickly came out with a statement that
noted
that that sentence had been taken out of
context you were talking about
the whole of government response not
president trump and of course you've
never endorsed a presidential candidate
in your five decades
of public service should the trump
campaign take this ad down
you know i think so jake i think it's
really unfortunate and
really disappointing that they did that
it's so clear that i'm not a political
person
and i have never either directly or
indirectly
endorsed a political candidate and to
take a completely out of contact
statement and put it in which is
obviously a political campaign and i i
thought was really very disappointing
what would you say if i told you i heard
that the trump campaign was actually
preparing to do another ad featuring you
you know that would be terrible i mean
that would be outrageous if they do that
um in fact that might actually come back
to backfire on them i
i hope they don't do that because that's
that would be kind of playing a game
that we don't want to play so i i hope
they reconsider that
if in fact they are indeed considering
doing that
i hope that they reconsider and not do
that that
mention of it might backfire is
something that has raised questions as
to whether fauci is threatening to quit
when fauci says this might backfire
there were questions are you threatening
to quit and he has said very clearly
he is not threatening to quit after that
interview fauci was interviewed by the
daily beast
and asked if he's considering quitting
he said not a chance
not in my wildest freaking dreams
did i ever think about quitting but he
did go on to say
that quote by doing this against my will
they are in effect
harassing me look at how backwards this
country is
dr fauci who is trying to save people
and keep people alive ended up needing
full-time security
thanks to harassment from trumpists dr
fauci's family
including his daughters required
security because they were being
threatened and fauci
is a public health expert he's being
forced to babysit a toddler
instead of save lives and to defend his
family from attacks with security
how can we be forgiven for this
constantly scapegoated
taken out of context denounced ignored
and pushed aside now for months and all
because
in his narcissistic mind donald trump
thinks he's the only one who can fix
things
and unfortunately many of trump's
sycophantic followers agree when trump
said well you know scientists
i know more than the scientists many of
his followers cheered that they went
right along with it and one of the
things i most look forward to about joe
biden winning if he wins
is dr fauci being treated the way he
deserves to be treated
coming back to the forefront of speaking
to the country
in an official capacity about how to
manage the pandemic
it would be nice to see fauci allowed to
do
what he should be doing what others in
faux's position in other countries are
being allowed
to do and you know these taking
fauchi out of context for a campaign ad
is the the lowest of the low and it
quite frankly isn't working remember
that dr fauci
is far more trusted than trump on the
virus
they've been trying to smear fauci for
months
and i guess you could say well the the
delta between
trump's trustworthiness on the virus and
fouches might be even bigger were it not
for the smear campaign
but the last numbers we have from from
last month
68 percent of americans say they trust
fauci
on the virus 40 say they trust trump
now that's depressing because how how
the hell
does 40 of the country trust trump on
the virus
but at least fouchy's trustworthiness is
almost twice what trump's is
but something is very wrong here when
trump says i know more than scientists
and people cheer
and 40 percent of the country still
trusts
trump on the virus we'll have more
coverage
of the out of context use of fouchy
video
by the trump campaign on the show's
instagram page
make sure you're following us there at
david pakmansha
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you forty percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we'll be speaking with josh dubin
who is a defense attorney and ambassador
advisor for the innocence project
a criminal justice reform advocate and
also host of the podcast
wrongful conviction junk science uh josh
it's so great to have you on today
thanks for having me happy to be here so
to just to start with
um can you talk a little bit about how
you
ended up working uh in the area
of uh wrongful conviction and and sort
of the path that led you to that
sure um you know i'd always been
interested
in um criminal justice reform
and i got a call when
i was like in my late 20s
i had this odd path because i was known
as a jury
um as a jury expert so i would get hired
by criminal defense lawyers to help them
pick
juries um that was the way it started in
some
civil attorneys as well so i got a call
from
barry scheck um who
i had known from watching the o.j
simpson trial when i was in college
um i actually thought it was my brother
pranking me
so i never returned the call and then
the person that the person that referred
me called me
his name is jerry lefcourt um who was
you know a civil rights icon he
represented
the panther 21 the black panthers at
that
their famous trial and abby hoffman
and uh he called me and said what what's
your problem i refer you to barry's
check and you don't call him back
so i called him back and um
i met barry and helped him with the case
and um it sort of took off from there
shortly thereafter barry sheck and peter
neufeld
had a civil practice a civil rights
practice
um where they were beginning to
represent people that they had
helped exonerate through the at the
innocence project in their
civil suits and i began working with him
and we really hit it off and it sort of
took off from there
so big big picture um you can find all
sorts of different reports that that uh
claim one in 25 people on death row is
innocent
or some percentage there's all the sort
of different numbers that that are
applied
uh generally speaking to to folks who
have been convicted
and are in prison what is a good way for
the layperson
to wrap their mind around what portion
of people convicted for serious crimes
um are are actually innocent of those
crimes
um you know it's difficult to tell
because
you don't know how many people are out
there
until you take on their cases so i don't
put much stock into the statistics but
i'll give you one that i do put a lot of
stock into
and this is only dealing with one state
you know the state of florida has 29
exonerations off of death row 29.
um they have only executed 99 people in
the state of florida
so i'm a shitty math student but if you
do the quick math
that shows you that a staggering
percentage of people that were sitting
on death row
awaiting execution um were
actually innocent i mean i was the lead
attorney
for clementi aguirre who was the 29th
exoneree from death row and i'm
currently representing
james daley who i think should be the
30th exoneree
um he's either going to be the 30th
exoneree or the 100th person
executed um so
i hope it's the former and not the
latter and i'm working real hard with my
team to make sure that that
isn't the case or that you know that it
is the case that he gets exonerated but
look
it's hard to know what percentage i
would venture to say
that it's much higher than people think
and
and it's a scary number um
because even one innocent person sitting
on death grows too much
so in interviews and documentaries i've
seen about the innocence project
uh and and with barry and peter one of
the things that
seems very important in so to set the
context
the innocence project gets far more
requests than the number that they can
take in in terms of the number of cases
that can be handled many of these cases
take
years uh to to be resolved so there's a
there's a selection process that happens
there and certainly it's important how
strongly
uh correct me if i'm wrong you feel that
the individual in question
is innocent but how much of the calculus
again given that there are limited
resources and unlimited number of cases
you can take
how much of the calculus is about the
likelihood that you could actually
get a a conviction overturned
um that's a good part of the calculus
you know
and and different criminal justice
reform organizations have different
criteria for how
um they go about assessing cases and
whether or not they'll take them you
know i have a little bit more
liberty because i don't work at the
innocence project although i'm
i'm an ambassador for the innocence
project so sometimes i take on innocence
project cases and that
they're they're my first love if you
will um
but you know i can say that
different people do this work for
different reasons
some people take a look at a case and
say you know what
there are terrible legal violations here
uh constitutional violations and that if
you know there's something worth
fighting for here irregardless of
their assessment of a person's guilt or
innocence
um and for me that's important
um and it's also important um
to me you know i think that look we're
human beings
um i think that the more i feel that
someone is innocent
the harder i think i'll fight whether on
a conscious or
or subconscious level so i think that
um likelihood of success
is definitely a factor but i can tell
you that
all of these exonerations are a an
arduous
battle a steep uphill climb you're
fighting against very tall odds
um so um i hope that that was a
long-winded way of answering your
question yeah i mean
how much does um a gut instinct
factor into your belief
about a possible case a possible
a person you'll represent a client's
guilt or or innocence how much of it is
gut and how much of it is reviewing the
facts
i try not to let my gut
lead me in one direction or another and
i try to
to base it on on facts
or or absence of facts and there's a
very there's a very particular reason
why i i sort of ascribe to that
and and why what is that because it's
got it's the gut of of detectives and
law enforcement
some some often times um
well-intentioned but extraordinarily
misguided that leads
to the wrongful um accusation in the
first place which leads to the core's
confession which relates to making up
evidence to make the
the um ends justify the means
that you know it's a it's a very
dangerous path to go down
um because i'm often humbled by
evidence or the lack of evidence that
conflicts with my gut so i try not to
let my gut
get too involved and because i again i
think that
you know it's oftentimes detectives um
feel like in their gut that if a spouse
is murdered
it's the surviving spouse that that did
it
and they started focusing on them
because that's their gut
and it can lead to tunnel vision and
confirmation bias and a whole host of
problems that
um are a pretty um
terrifying slippery slope for the
accused
there are a very long list of
reasons and different ways in which
innocent people can end up convicted and
as you're talking about
uh tunnel vision from investigators can
be a way where
where somebody becomes the suspect
relatively early on at the exclusion of
maybe others
junk science is another um aspect of
this
and um for example forensic dentistry is
one that's been explored
significantly and has been involved in a
lot of uh retrials or
or um exonerations can you talk a little
bit about
how would you sort of categorize the the
different
buckets that would be the main ways in
which innocent people end up convicted
yeah no that's a great question you know
one of the things it's also a natural
segue for me to plug the podcast but
you know on our podcast wrongful
conviction junk science
we explore a different discipline of
junk science on every episode
and it's not something that i'm plucking
out of thin air
um i am doing it in large part based on
the national academy of sciences
report in 2009 that examined
these various disciplines of forensic
dentistry
and essentially found that the only one
that that is reputable and has any
bankable
reliable science behind it is dna so
we examine everything from bite marks as
you mentioned
forensic dentistry to arson
to um you know
footwear impressions to ballistics
to gunshot residue to fingerprints think
about that
we have always been taught in pop
culture
on true crime shows that fingerprints
are the gold standard and they're not
um and if you really examine any of
these
um disciplines of forensic science you
find out that
even attaching the word forensic to it
or calling it a science is a misnomer
because
many of them were born in in basements
and
at the hands of some crackpot that did
not get
um even minimal buy-in from the
scientific community
much less apply the scientific method
and
they get accepted in one case and
because of our
our system of legal precedent they all
all of a sudden start spreading through
the justice system
and you know we get these um
you know various forms of of alleged
science that
um you you need a 40-hour correspondence
course to get
declared an expert in and you know you
you end up with
with real problems my full conversation
with josh dubin will be available on the
david pakman
show youtube channel very very soon at
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show we will go
to a quick
break and be back after this the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as
one dollar per month or as much as you
want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so donald trump did another rally last
night this one was in pennsylvania where
donald trump is now losing to joe biden
by an
average of seven points and donald trump
actually asked women to like him during
yesterday's rally we will get to that
but let's start in order piece by piece
donald trump
kicking off the rally by slamming joe
biden because joe biden abandoned
pennsylvania
when he was 10 years old hell do you
lose to a guy like this is this positive
oh i'll never come to pennsylvania again
i love this place
you know they say he was born in
scranton but he left
he left he abandoned you he said give me
a break
this would be like uh attacking me for
abandoning
argentina when i was five as if at age
five i could have said
thanks mom and dad i'm gonna stick
around here instead of moving to the
united states with you a really
strange line of attack but nothing
matters to these crowds
they will cheer anything this next one i
love
i don't know if you guys have seen but
pete boudage edge
or buddha judge has been on fox news a
lot lately
crushing crushing trump so trump
apparently doesn't like it and he talked
about pete but a judge
at yesterday's rally except he called
him booty check which is uh
different you had uh alfred newman you
had all these people
you know who alfred e newman is yes pete
budeck
pete budeck he's a bad mayor of a failed
town and he's going to run for president
you know
just uh just wild stuff i mean it's
insane that this is the reality we live
in and then here's that strangest moment
of the entire thing when donald trump
asked
suburban women to like him a sort of uh
jeb bush please clap moment except much
more cringy this was after about
90 seconds of ranting incoherently i
don't want to build low income housing
next to your house okay if that's okay
and i ended the regulation the rule that
made the zoning so impossible that you
had to destroy your communities
and then i hear the suburban woman i
think that the suburban woman
and i used to say suburban housewife i
used to take heat but i said
does anybody care do you care if i say
surprise no they're all going no
again the only one cares is them trump
said suburban housewife but i didn't say
it
because i don't you learn very quickly
you learn very quickly
but suburban women they should like me
more than anybody here tonight
because i ended the regulation
that destroyed your neighborhood i ended
the regulation that brought
crime to the suburbs and you're going to
live the american dream and that's what
you're going to do
and remember this 29
of the people experiencing the american
dream in the suburbs happen to be
minority and you don't know that but 29
and we're doing this for everybody we're
not doing it one way the other we're
doing it
and i ended it they said sir we can
amend it i said i don't want to amend it
i want to end it it was a horror show
and this loser corey booker is the guy
that's going to be in charge of the
program the guy's a stone called loser
one percent he got one percent he ran he
was going to be great you know one
percent
every week he was like her down down
down they should have picked him
but no he'll be in charge of your uh
suburban so can
i ask you to do me a favor suburban
women would you please like me
remember please
is that a message of hope and change or
what right suburban women
please like me that you may want to
workshop that messaging to women a
little bit it could probably you you
might want to focus group that a little
bit before you you you commit to
women please like me then donald trump
again pulling out this line that he's
now immune to reinfection from
coronavirus
and wants to kiss all the men and women
in the audience
let's take a look at this next clip and
now i'm immune they tell me i'm immune i
could come down and start kissing
everybody
i'll kiss every guy man and woman man
and woman look at that guy how handsome
he is
i'll kiss him not not with a lot of
enjoyment but that's okay
joe biden would terminate our recovery
delay the vaccine
one of the funniest things about donald
trump's rallies
is you can tell from his tone
when he's kind of riffing and when he's
on the teleprompter and sometimes
the contrast is so stark when he goes
from riffing back to the prompter
which by the way he did it there he he
slams biden all the time for using a
teleprompter trump using one as well
it's almost jarring when trump gets back
on the prompter because it's like two
different speeches woven together in a
bizarre amalgam of insanity
trump then asked the crowd how many of
you have had coronavirus
now this is funny for a few reasons
first of all he congratulates them
for being immune which as you all know
there are still questions about
reinfection how long immunity lasts etc
not particularly responsible for for
trump to go head first on this
but you know when you have people
crowded together during a pandemic
asking the infected folks even if it's
previous i mean who really knows when
when they last
uh had it or would have tested positive
asking people to raise their hands to
say i had coronavirus you're not going
to get a lot of takers i don't think but
regardless trump tries it take a look
i'm hard the fda has been great to
everyone fighting to recover from the
virus
i feel your pain because i felt your
pain
and we will beat this virus together
and for those who has had it who has had
it here who's had it
yeah a lot of people a lot of people
you're the people i want to say hello to
because you're right now immune
you're right now immune or they say that
you know they hate to admit it because i
had it
not how i would try to get a crowd fired
up
by having those masked together who have
had coronavirus
put their hands up and say yeah i had it
not not exactly making people feel too
good and then donald trump wrapping up
with this pre-packaged piece of his
stump speech that he's been using a lot
now and the crowd just
loves it nation under god and together
with the incredible people of
pennsylvania
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
and we will make america safe again
and we will make america great
again thank you very much pennsylvania
thank you get out and vote
vote vote vote completely and utterly
surreal events we hopefully are down to
the last three weeks of trump rallies
we will ever have and then done so if we
vote if we if we get it done
uh tonight 7 p.m eastern trump will be
in iowa i will be live
on youtube twitch and facebook i hope
you'll join me for
audience participation and live
commentary
if not i understand i i really do and
hopefully
we're down to the last three weeks of
this we've talked before about the
kentucky senate race a longtime
republican senator and current senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell
has a real challenge uh in former marine
and democratic nominee amy mcgrath
they recently debated and disgusting
mitch mcconnell
just laughing cackling when amy mcgrath
confronted him about his
abject failures in dealing with
coronavirus
he just laughs he's laughing as more
than two hundred thousand have died take
a look at this
a house passed a bill in may
and and this this the senate went on
vacation
i mean you just don't do that you you
negotiate senator it is a national
crisis
you knew that the coronavirus wasn't
going to end at the end of july
we knew this i mean i just think you've
got to
and here's the thing if you want to call
yourself a leader so bill you
if you want to call yourself a leader
you got to get things done
those of us that served in the marines
we don't just point fingers at the other
side
we get the job done senator you went on
vacation
when people needed coronavirus relief
quite a guy right i mean we we have to
assume i
i really believe in giving people the
benefit of the doubt and i know there
are
every state has a lot of ideological
nutty right wingers
we have to assume that not all
kentuckians actually like mitch
mcconnell don't we in other words
part of why mitch mcconnell has been in
power for so long
has to be that many people simply aren't
paying attention and don't
actually endorse this guy's complete and
total immorality i hope for the sake of
humanity
that that's the case at least to some
extent here's more of mitch mcconnell
laughing off accurate statements from
amy mcgrath
about the supreme court about
coronavirus relief about everything
this montage includes part of the clip i
showed you just a couple minutes ago
and he's walking away from negotiations
even now
when president trump even wants
negotiations to happen before this
election
it's it's irresponsible senator
mcconnell
and instead of doing that he is trying
to ram through a supreme court nominee
right now
instead of negotiating which is what he
should have been doing
all summer long to make that happen
senator you have an additional response
we've got to get our democracy working
because we have to get through this
crisis right now that's your time
senator mcconnell
well senate went on vacation
i mean you just don't do that you you
negotiate senator it is a national
crisis
you knew that the coronavirus wasn't
going to end at the end of july
if you want to call yourself a leader
you got to get things done
those of us that served in the marines
we don't just point fingers at the other
side
we get the job done is it all a joke to
mitch mcconnell
or or does he at least see amy mcgrath
as a joke is that what it is because
that's the laugh of a hypocrite
unfortunately there are many voters in
kentucky who think
at least he's not a democrat and they're
going to vote for him
that counts for a lot in many republican
strongholds like kentucky but
imagine removing mitch mcconnell on
november 3rd
it's an uphill battle no doubt but if
you look at 538.com
it says mcconnell has a 96 chance of
being reelected
the truth is we don't have very recent
polling in kentucky if you look at the
polls on real clear politics you'll see
the latest poll is nearly a month old
yes mcconnell was leading by 12 then
but that was a month ago a lot has
happened since then it could be six
right now within three weeks
it could be less than six we just have
no idea
and it's a great race to get involved in
and then briefly just as a reminder
south carolina incumbent republican
senator lindsey graham
has a serious challenge from democratic
candidate jamie harrison harrison has
been raising
ungodly amounts of money lately but the
concern is
how much of the money is from around the
country rather than from
voters in south carolina but the latest
polls there are good for harrison
in the last month the polls are a thai
lindsey graham ahead by one and two more
ties
if you go beyond that you're looking at
polling from july very
important race i think harrison has more
of a shot than mcgrath
but both really key races that you can
get yourself involved in
phone banking uh door-to-door
campaigning if you live in the states
and you can do it safely
etc get involved get involved and we are
going to talk on today's bonus show
about some of these races and more as
well
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com we'll see you then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video